le style roussel c'est avant tout celui
de la proximité c'est aussi le style du
candidat positif et optimiste ce qui le
des tâches de manière très forte de ses
concurrents
je suis un ch'ti un député du nord je
vis j'ai grandi dans le bassin minier
qui a vu ses usines se délocaliser
partir et en laissant derrière du
chômage et de la pauvreté c'est terminé
l'argent l'argent dont le pape dit qu'il
est le fumier du diable tout c'est
l'amour d'abord nous et la fraternité
d'abord nous mais l'humain d'abord label
rouge c'est justement
on la belle qu'on sente qu'il ya pour le
coup une tonalité extrêmement différente
de celle de ses rivaux le style roussel
c'est la proximité c'est la connivence
c'est l'humour c'est la capacité à
embarquer la salle et à permettre à tous
ou en tout cas à tous ces militants
d'adhérer de façon extrêmement forte et
immédiate à ses idées bonjour l'import
je promets distribuer des tracts c'est
tout ça
et que personne ne vienne me dire
roussel touche pas au grisbi
si parce qu'il est temps de s'attaquer
au mur de l'argent de reprendre le
pouvoir à la finance
c'est justement cette capacité à jouer
sur les images à jouer sur l'humour à
jouer sur les métaphores qui lui permet
de créer tout au long du meeting des
moments très forts d'entre eux dias mais
d'élan qui finalement permettre
d'entretenir cette relation de proximité
de connivence avec son public et à la
fois beaucoup d'émotion quand il
présente tout ce discours social qui est
vraiment le coeur de son programme et
puis il a aussi cette capacité à
s'insurger et qui pour lui il fait
complètement partie pour le coude de
l'arsenal de techniques qu'ils mettent
en place lors de ses discours
écoutez bien l'argent qu'ils se
concentrent dans les mains de ses trois
cent cinquante huit mille familles les
plus riches l'argent l'argent des
multinationales l'âge
l'argent dont le pape dit qu'il est le
fumier du diable et l'argent dont
mitterrand bizet qu'il corrompt jusqu'à
la conscience de l'âme et ne faudrait
pas en parler et bien c'est nous ne
parlait que de cela
une des façons de conquérir la foule et
de maintenir son public dans dans un
élan très enthousiasmés et celui de
lysel de différentes figures de style
c'est vrai que dans ce discours tout
l'anaphore sur l'argent et cette
tonalité très accusatoire donne
évidemment à ce discours une une
tonalité particulière
l'idée c'est d'embarquer complètement la
salle avec lui cette authenticité elle
se traduit aussi par ses gestes
extrêmement spontanée est extrêmement
nombreux à la tribune c'est un effet
quelqu'un qui pour le coup cherche à
montrer un vrai contraste dans les mots
et dans la posture avec les image plus
lisse et beaucoup plus guidés et
travailler que peuvent être celle de
valérie pécresse d'emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs même d'anne hidalgo d'un
grand nombre de ses concurrents on a
accès à la pensée direct du candidat à
travers
la spontanéité du langage mais on a
aussi accès à sa personnalité réelle à
travers ses gestes qui ne sont qui ne
sont pas travailler et qui ne sont pas
réfléchi en amont le fait d'avoir accès
à cette forme de spontanéité et
d'authenticité et justement quelque
chose que recherchent de plus en plus
les électeurs qui sont aujourd'hui plus
du tout dupe des stratégies de
communication et des postures qui sont
choisis par les candidats et qui sont à
la recherche justement d'une parole
décomplexée fabien roussel marque des
points de façon très nette en
choisissant d'avoir cette posture très
très naturelle et décomplexée qui crée
un lien différent
avec avec les français
[Musique]
il faut quand même le dire est
démystifié je vois tous ces gangs
d'arnaqueurs qui prennent la parole les
macron pécresse le pen zemmour qui
prétendent augmenter les salaires
qui prétendent augmenter les salaires au
baissant les cotisations sociales
ils chassent aussi avec cette signature
lexical sur les terres de jean luc
mélenchon puisque on est vraiment dans
la façon de manier l'humour de manier
les images très concrètes plutôt que les
concepts c'est quelque chose on retrouve
de façon assez similaire chez ces deux
candidats ça lui permet d'abord de créer
un vrai effet de rupture par rapport aux
autres candidats ça c'était une évidence
puisqu'ils sont les seuls à jouer sur
sur ses ressorts politiques là qui sont
ceux de l'authenticité de la proximité
de la vérité de la transparence donc en
opposition à une image plus techno et
lisse puisqu'ils incarnent eux mêmes de
façon extrêmement fortes et puissantes
les idées qu'ils défendent et c'est
peut-être évidemment plus difficile à
faire quand on a une image extrêmement
lisse et travailler et que par ailleurs
on a un programme plus consensuel la
seule façon finalement de faire percer
un programme clivant qui est un
programme extrêmes et radicales peuvent
l'être le programme d'extrême gauche
c'est d'incarner de manière très très
forte ces programmes en en étant leurs
principaux porte parole et fabien
roussel hier exprime bien
[Musique]